[Music]
the Gothic leaders alaric and gainst
Erick not exactly household names
anymore but in chapter 34 we come to
someone who certainly is
everybody knows the name Attila the Hun
this chapter and the four that follow it
will describe successive waves of
invaders who would ultimately make their
own important contribution to modern
Europe previous invading groups have
been loose shifting Federation's of
tribes occasionally organizing into a
collaborative force more often
quarreling among themselves Huns were
something new and they challenged the
Roman Empire with a virtual Empire of
their own in the reign of Attila Gibbon
says the Huns again became the terror of
the world we may recognize that illest a
but we don't necessarily know much about
him apart from the tiresome cliche that
people keep repeating as if it were
witty that somebody's politics are to
the right of Attila the Hun till it
could be brutal but even if he'd been a
mass murderer that wouldn't identify him
as right-wing Joseph Stalin was a mass
murderer in the large sweep of Gibbons
narrative this is the culmination in the
chain reaction of successive groups that
moved westward he describes them as very
much like a natural phenomenon in the
tide of immigration which impetuously
rolled from the confines of China to
those of Germany the most powerful and
populous tribes they commonly be found
on the verge of the Roman provinces
where they acquired an eager appetite
for the luxuries of civilized life this
tide of emigration is a human equivalent
to the terrible earthquake that
devastated the Mediterranean region not
long before the earthquake that was
described back in chapter 26 happened in
the year 365 the Huns entered the
picture in 376 those earlier tribes then
have developed an appetite for civilized
luxury which from Gibbons point of view
was good and Dee barber eyes them the
more primitive
weren't interested in that given
introduces a tiller with a vivid
portrait a large head with for the
complexion
small deep-seated eyes a flat nose few
hairs and places a beard broad shoulders
and a short square body of nervous
strength though of a disproportioned
form the haughty step and demeanor of
the king of the Huns expressed the
consciousness of his superiority above
the rest of mankind and he had a custom
of fiercely rolling his eyes as if he
wished to enjoy the terror which he
inspired so far we might be hearing
about one of the orcs in the Lord of the
Rings but then the tongue changes yet
this savage hero was not inaccessible to
pity his suppliant enemies might confide
in the assurance of peace or pardon an
Attila was considered by his subjects as
a just an indulgent master he delighted
in war but after he had ascended the
throne and a mature age his head rather
than his hand achieved the conquest of
the north and the fame of an adventurous
soldier was usefully exchanged for that
of a prudent and successful general
presentation here is impressively
judicious to unite those disparate
groups a true general was needed one
might even say a statesman
although the Huns first entered the
consciousness of the Roman world back in
376 it was not until 434 that the Hunnic
Empire was consolidated under Attila F
so often given doesn't supply the dates
that would help us to keep our bearings
or at least it's conventional to call it
an empire the better where it might be
hegemony the formerly nomadic Huns made
their headquarters somewhere in Upper
Hungary which takes its name from them
the lifestyle is still rustic the palace
made entirely would given took it as
axiomatic a proper palace made of stone
and he also remarks that over the extent
of several thousand miles the Empire of
the Huns didn't contain a single City
Peter Heather in his excellent book the
fall of the Roman Empire describes the
exceptional skill of the Huns on
horseback and their powerful laminated
bows which could wound on armored foes
at a distance of 400 yards at closer
quarters not even the simple armor in
those days with adequate protection in
450 Attila soldiers were on the move
their plan was to conquer Gaul with the
assistance of some of the resident
vandals and franks who became their
allies Gibbon seems to treat this
campaign as resulting from mere
belligerents but from a modern
perspective there was a more calculated
motive the hunnic Confederation was
unstable they could fragment at any time
Attila needed victories to keep it
together
and after they finished ransacking the
region along the Danube new targets had
to be found as always barbarian troops
had little hope of capturing heavily
fortified Constantinople
so therefore Gaul an impressive alliance
of tribal groups in golf came together
to resist the Huns and you could hear
Gibbon savoring their names as he gives
a resonant role call the laity the
Armagh Ricans briones the Saxons
the Burgundians the formations or Aulani
the RIP to Aryans and the Franks such
she goes on with the various army which
under the conduct of ETS and Theodoric
advanced by rapid marches to relieve
Orly home and to give battle to the
innumerable host of attila diaw drake
was a king of the Ostrogoths and
flavia's Aegeus has been described as
the last great roman hero as a young
soldier he had spent time with the Huns
as a hostage and that gave him unusual
insight into their culture and methods
though he was never named Emperor he
really was the de facto Emperor in the
West at this time the opposing forces
met in an enormous battle in 451 on the
Catalonian Plains known in French as the
Battle of Shiloh about a hundred miles
east of Paris
the historical record is very sketchy
here it's not at all clear what happened
except that Theodoric the Visigoths was
killed not by a hun but by a javelin
hurled by an Ostrogoth who was allied
with Attila the fighting ended in a
stalemate after horrific bloodshed but
at any rate Gaul was saved
Attila withdrew his forces decided to
attack Italy instead on the way
atrocities were committed not just by
Huns but by their allies a group of
syringe Ian's who came from central
Germany decided to get rid of some
hostages they had taken but
characteristic vividness Gibbon
describes what happened they massacred
their hostages as well as their captives
two hundred young maidens were tortured
with exquisite and unrelenting rage
their bodies were torn asunder by wild
horses or their bones were crushed under
the weight of rolling wagons and their
unburied limbs were abandoned on the
public roads as a prey to dogs and
vultures such given says were those
savage ancestors whose imaginary virtues
have sometimes excited the praise and
Envy is civilized ages given as thinking
of something that would become even more
prevalent after his time the tendency of
French and German writers to idealize
their ancestors in 452 the Huns captured
Milan which was duly sacked and given
pauses from this narrative to describe
one remarkable consequence of the
invasion up until then the name Venetia
or Venice referred to a large inland
region along the east coast of Italy to
escape the barbarians a number of
families took refuge at this point on a
hundred small islands in the lagoon
living by fishing at first and gradually
connecting the islands is what we now
know is the great city of Venice it was
a republic from the beginning not a
monarchy and it remained an increasingly
rich and powerful one until Napoleon
finally captured and looted it in 1797
meanwhile Attila made an unusual
proposal he wanted to marry the princess
han Oriya the older sister
the emperor Valentinian the third this
episode gives given a chance to tell a
tragically romantic tale at the age of
sixteen anuria had gotten pregnant after
sleeping with her chamberlain Eugenius
and was punished by exile in a convent
in constantinople desperate to get out
of there after 10 years of virtual
imprisonment she wrote to Attila
offering herself to him and along with
the letter she enclosed a ring given is
clearly shocked wondering how she could
think of marrying a barbarian of whose
language she was ignorant whose figure
was scarcely human and whose religion
and manners she abhorred her attempt was
discovered and this time she went to
prison for good it's interesting though
Gibbon doesn't blame anuria for her
furtive affair she'd been forbidden to
marry until a suitable dynastic alliance
might be found she was understandably
reluctant to comply as he describes it
Honora aside yielded to the impulsive
nature and threw herself into the arms
of her chamberlain Eugenius the story is
a good example of Gibbons tolerant
attitude towards sex
it was the impulsive nature that drove
the frustrated young woman into the arms
of a palace attendant and given is not
critical in the least but he does
criticize what he calls unchastity he
means flagrant infidelity in either sex
not just women as for a Atilla it was
wealth and power he was after not sex he
already had a large number of wives and
while waiting for an answer concerning
anuria he married yet another beautiful
young woman after his wedding night he
failed to emerge from his bedroom and
when his alarmed attendance broke in
they found him dead from a burst artery
the bride sat by the bed hiding her face
and weeping for fear she might be blamed
Gibbon describes with distaste how the
Hung's fallen Lee buried their ruler
executing a number of captives along
with him and then enjoyed a wild drunken
celebration it is not say and his
sources are unclear on this what
happened to the unfortunate bride the
sudden death marked the end of the honey
empire which in retrospect made the
memory of Attila
all the more potent Gibbon says the
revolution which subvert the Empire of
the Huns established the fame of Attila
whose genius alone had sustained the
huge and disjointed fabric these words
were published ten years before the
French Revolution gave the modern
meaning to the word revolution forgiving
it still had its classical meaning of
revolving the endless cyclical process
by which one political order is replaced
by another the emperor Valentinian was
jealous at his general ets and in 454 he
personally stabbed each us to death
Valentinian in turn was murdered by
accomplices of maximus a roman senator
whose wife he had raped the injured
senator was then made emperor in his
place but not for long Maximus turned
out to have no leadership ability at all
after just three months a vandal army
under Gimmes Erick showed up and
threatened Rome an angry mob demanded
that maximus come out from his palace to
deal with the crisis and when he did
they pelted him with stones a soldier
then ran him through with a sword and
his body was flown into the Tiber we've
encountered incidents much like that one
before this was a revolution and the old
sense of the word in chapter 36 Gibbon
gives a survey of the development of the
Barbarian kingdoms not really so
barbarian anymore and he narrates as
economically as possible the depressing
sequence of no fewer than nine Roman
emperors during a space of just twenty
years but the start of the chapter a
concise list of topics tells the story
sack of Rome by Gensler rich king of the
vandals his naval depredations
succession of the last emperors of the
West Maximus abacus Maggiore 'n Severus
anthemius glib rias fly serious at NEPA
guff stylist total extinction of the
western empire reign of oda locker
the first barbarian king of Italy
the Vandals under against Drake did
indeed sack Rome which was getting
sacked regularly by now and a vandal
naval force captured Sicily as well as
North Africa thereafter their pirate
ships pillage towns all over the
Mediterranean back when the Empire was
strong pirates they used to be
suppressed ruthlessly in 476 it was
finally over the last of the Emperor's
was named Romulus Augustus but as Gibbon
observes the second name has been
changed by the Latins into the
contemptible diminutive Augustus which
means little Augustus he resigned
willingly and the Senate informed the
emperor in Constantinople that all
remained of the Western Empire now
belong to him
odo Walker whose ethnic origin is
uncertain was hailed as king not Emperor
I was generous enough to let Romulus
Augustus retire to a rural estate Oda
Walker sent to Constantinople the diadem
and purple cloak that only an emperor
could wear and as Peter Heather says
this momentous act brought half a
millennium of empire to a close from the
perspective of Constantinople this fall
of the Western Empire was merely
symbolic as was the so called momentous
act of turning over the Imperial
insignia April Cameron calls it a
non-event Gibbons head note to the
chapter dramatically announced the
extinction of the Western Empire we
really all have changed with the
administrative structure at the top and
that was already practically useless
insofar as there was a change it was for
the better
odo Walker was far more capable than the
feeble Emperor's who preceded him in
Gibbons words the king of Italy was not
unworthy of the high station to which
his valor and fortune had exalted him
his savage manners were polished by the
habits of conversation and he respected
though a conqueror and the barbarian
institutions should even the prejudices
of his subjects
odo Walker incidentally
the Latin pronunciation in England where
foreign names tend to be pronounced as
if they were English its Odoacer the
Vandals were the people who gave
vandalism a bad name but from their own
point of view they had courageously won
the right to settle down in some of the
best regions in the former Empire over a
span of thirty years they had forced
their way across France into Spain and
now North Africa they weren't invaders
anymore or even immigrants they were
simply inhabitants unlike the Goths
before them even when they carried
valuables away from Rome they didn't
really damage the city itself given no
doubt remembering his original
meditations in the ruins of the capital
stresses that it was actually later
Romans who gradually demolished the
great public structures he says The
Spectator who casts a mournful view over
the ruins of ancient Rome is tempted to
accuse the memory of the Goths and
vandals for the mischief which they had
neither leisure nor power nor perhaps
inclination to perpetrate the
destruction which undermined the
foundations of those masih fabrics was
prosecuted slowly and silently during a
period of ten centuries they were
esteemed only is it inexhaustible mine
of materials cheaper and more convenient
than the distant quarry given will
return to this thought at the very end
of the decline in fall in Chapter 37 we
return once more to religion and to the
growth of a novel institution that was
monasticism which originated originated
in Egypt and spread through the West as
with the Byzantine Empire generally
given as a serious blind spot here it's
one that he shared with most Protestant
English people who regarded monks and
nuns as agents of Popish superstition
and as idlers living at other peoples
expense they were also appalled by the
extreme salt mortification of the early
monks as early as the reign of
Constantine some devout ascetics had
decided that society was unacceptably
world late and they moved out altogether
the word monk comes
the Greek mana cost one who lives alone
some of them formed small communities in
the wilderness always it the same sex of
course others lived completely alone as
Hermits Gibbons introduction of them
sets the tone clearly the ascetics who
obeyed and abused the rigid precepts of
the gospel were inspired by the savage
enthusiasm which represents man as a
criminal and God as a tyrant they
seriously renounced the business and the
pleasures of the age observed the use of
wine of flesh and of marriage chastised
their body mortified their affection and
embraced a life of misery as the price
is eternal happiness they themselves
wouldn't have called it misery of course
given is always suspicious a fanatical
enthusiasm here he calls it savage
enthusiasm but he also criticizes the
monks for its predictable opposite
superstition so a few pages later he
says these unhappy exiled from social
life were impelled by the dark and
implacable genius of superstition it's
not clear whether he means they chose
their vocation because they were already
unhappy or that they became unhappy
afterward first of all from given point
of view these unproductive idlers had
chosen a way of life that was virtually
subhuman the lives of the primitive
monks he says were consumed in penance
and solitude undisturbed by the various
occupations which fill the time and
exercise the faculties of reasonable
active and social beings and there are
silent meals they were enveloped in
their cowls inaccessible and almost
invisible to each other a very different
from the sociable Edward Gibbon who
enjoy a good talk good food and good
wine
the one thing given well grant is since
the monks were sincere in fact they were
all too sincere from that point of view
they were very different from later
monks as enlightenment philosophers
perceived them some of those later ones
gained great political influence and
many of them had no intention of
refusing pleasure Gibbon flips in a
slide footnote
I've somewhere heard or read the Frank
confession of a Benedictine abbot my vow
of poverty has given me a hundred
thousand crowns a year by vow of
obedience has raised me to the rank of a
Sovereign Prince Gibbon adds I forget
the consequence of his vow of chastity
one of the earliest Egyptian monks was
the subject of a famous biography by
none other than the great Athanasius
that would sink Antony the ideal type of
the holy man whose special charisma
derived from fervent unworldliness
Antony gave away all his possessions and
lived in a solitary cell in the desert
he was celebrated for fighting valiantly
there against temptations by demons
mostly sexual in nature a favorite
subject in later art Gibbon mentions him
only briefly for his intrepid fanaticism
more congenial to Gibbon Sade is the
spectacular performance of Saint Simeon
style tease or Stylites the title came
from the Greek word Telos a pillar or
column for the saint lived for 39 years
on top of a high pillar in Syria without
ever once coming down the modern Greek
poet Konstantin Cavafy filled his copy
of Gibbons decline and fall with
thoughtful comments at this point he
wrote this great this wonderful Saint is
surely an object to be singled out in
history for admiration and study
he has been perhaps the only man who was
dared to be really alone
that was exactly what mainstream 18th
century attitudes deplored solitude was
thought to encourage mental illness
Protestants would regard
Antony's demons as sick fantasies caused
by excessive Santis fasting in an
unbalanced imagination actually Saint
Simeon was only technically alone crowds
of pilgrims came to gaze admiring Lee up
at the aesthetic hero Peter Brown who is
sympathetic in general to the monastic
movement mentions that Simeon was seen
to touch his toes twelve hundred and
forty four times while bowing before God
Browne adds the true horror of this
story why it's not in the exertions of
the saint but in the layman who stood
there counting there was even a ladder
to prevent visitors to climb up and
confer with the saint receiving advice
or asking to be healed from the cultural
perspective it's clear that Gibbons
criticism of monasticism is badly
off-base
most monks lived in communities not
alone and they were expected to work
hard as well as to pray in an economy
built on slavery there was high
unemployment for free men entering a
monastery offered a viable way of life
in both Santa and later monasteries took
up many of the public services the
government was increasingly unable to
perform chapter 38 they seemed somewhat
out of place an overview of the
development of a Frankish Kingdom that
was turning recognizably into France
there's also a rather hasty glance at
Spain and Brittany not until volume 4
will give and return to the newly
established Gothic Kingdom of Italy and
for our purposes it would be best to
postpone talking about those emerging
kingdoms until then volume 3 ends with
an enthusiastic tribute to 18th century
Europe which given sees as having
attained the very height of civilization
the feel of self like to call themselves
citizens of the world and Gibbon who was
at home in France and Switzerland as
much as in England shared that attitude
a patriot he says may prefer the glory
of his own country but a philosopher may
be permitted to enlarge his you and to
consider Europe as one great Republic
whose various inhabitants have attained
almost the same level of politeness and
cultivation to be sure war is still
flare up but they're settled fairly
amicably this partial events he says
cannot essentially injure our general
state of happiness the system of Arts
and laws and manners which so
advantageous ly distinguish above the
rest of mankind the Europeans and their
colonies
and just in case anyone might wonder if
invaders from outside could still
destroy this happy equilibrium given
assure his readers that would be
impossible cannon and fortifications now
form an impregnable barrier against the
Tartar horse and Europe is secure from
any future eruption of barbarians since
before they can conquer
they must cease to be barbarous their
gradual advances in the science of war
would always be accompanied as we may
learn from the example of Russia with a
proportionable improvement in the arts
of peace and civil policy and they
themselves must deserve a place among
the polish nations who may subdue given
us thinking of the Russia of Peter the
Great
like the Prussia of Frederick the Great
both of whom saw themselves as
enlightened philosopher Kings he can't
be blamed for not foreseeing the Russia
of Stalin or the Germany and Hitler what
is surprising is that when the French
Revolution erupted with all its savagery
he was absolutely incredulous it turned
out the general state of happiness was
not so very secure after all in
historical hindsight the complacency of
enlightenment has sometimes been blamed
for encouraging an immoral development
of Technology without an adequate moral
perspective to control it after the fall
of France in 1940 Winston Churchill gave
his immortal speech declaring that the
Battle of Britain was about to begin in
that speech Churchill said this if we
fail then the whole world including the
United States including all that we have
known and cared for will sink into the
abyss of a new Dark Age made more
sinister and perhaps more protracted by
the lights of perverted science let us
therefore brace ourselves to our duties
and so bear ourselves that if the
British Empire and it's Commonwealth
lasts for a thousand years men will
still say this was their finest hour
science did indeed play a role in
devastating human lives
on a colossal scale and as Gibbon and
his contemporaries were already
beginning to suspect their own Empire
would have very finite lifespans the
British Empire was destined to end only
a few years after Churchill's speech at
the end of his third volume which
concluded the 1781 installment of the
decline and fall given added an
unnumbered concluding chapter entitled
general observations on the fall of the
Roman Empire in the West it's here that
he makes the point we quoted previously
the decline of Rome was the natural and
inevitable effect of a moderate
greatness as soon as time or accident
had removed the artificial supports the
stupendous fabric yielded to the
pressure of its own weight the story of
its ruin is simple and obvious that
instead of enquiring why the Roman
Empire was destroyed we should rather be
surprised that it subsisted so long the
key word is fabric which is that time
usually referring to architectural
structures not cloth given knew a great
deal about architecture he read up on it
with supervising reconstruction of his
family home and what he had in mind was
the equilibrium of forces under tension
that makes a structure stand once those
get out of balance gravity takes over
and the entire thing can collapse the
project given it originally said himself
was now accomplished and an astonishing
achievement it was in the standard
modern edition these 39 chapters in the
PostScript fill more than 1500 pages
supported by thousands of learning
footnotes should the book simply end
here would be a tremendous task to
master the subsequent history of the
empire in the east but in the preface to
the first volume of the decline and fall
published back in 1776 given it sketched
out three historical stages in the story
and only the first of those stages was
now complete this is what he said back
then the first of these periods may be
traced from the age of Trajan and the
Antonine when the Roman monarchy having
attained its full strength and maturity
began to verge towards its decline and
will extend
the subversion of the Western Empire by
the barbarians of Germany and Sathya the
rude ancestors of the most polished
nations of modern Europe this
extraordinary revolution which subjected
Rome to the power of a gothic Conqueror
was completed about the beginning of the
6th century that is the story we've now
seen brilliantly told but as given well
knew much more would still happen before
the final end of the empire in the east
nearly a thousand years later the
temptation to tell that story was great
it would prove to be irresistible so in
1781 when he reprinted that 1776 preface
he added a PS the entire history which
is now published of the decline and fall
of the Roman Empire in the West
abundantly discharges my engagements
with the public perhaps their favorable
opinion may encourage me to prosecute a
work which however laborious it may seem
is the most agreeable occupation of my
leisure hours